autobahnen die strom produzieren oder
intelligente straßen die schäden oder
glatteis direkt an die entsprechenden
stellen kommunizieren oder sich sogar
selbst reparieren genau solche ideen in
sachen straßenbau werden jetzt auf einem
neuartigen testgelände in deutschland
auf herz und nieren geprüft wie
realistisch diese pläne sind und wie
wohl die zukunft unserer verkehrsstraßen
aussieht jetzt in klicks und science
fiction herzlich willkommen
selbst wenn bauingenieure heutzutage
eine richtig coole innovative idee haben
dauert es rund 30 jahre um eine neue
straßenbau technik auch tatsächlich auf
die straße zu bringen und nach solch
einer langen zeitspanne ist die technik
alles nur nicht mehr innovativ sie ist
schon ein alter hut vor allem auch bei
der gegebenen veralteten infrastruktur
und der zunehmenden verkehrsdichte sind
die neuen verfahren dann auch gerne
schon mal überholen nicht zu vergessen
auch zunehmende extreme wetterlagen wie
uns in zukunft vielleicht über mehrere
wochen hitze hitze von rund 40 grad
bescheren werden die bundesanstalt für
straßenwesen bast hat jetzt ein riesiges
forschungs areal in köln realisiert wo
neue entwicklungen in sachen verkehr der
zukunft getestet werden hier forscht
deutschland also an den autobahnen und
strafen der zukunft es geht um neue
baustoffe bauverfahren und auch
bauweisen der traum eines jeden
verkehrsplaners heißt nur abbas und
steht für demonstrations- untersuchungs
und referenz areal der passt jetzt
gerade wurde es im autobahnkreuz
köln-ost auf einem nicht gebrauchten
autobahnstück eröffnet da hatte man in
den 70er jahren ein wenig zu aufwändig
gebaut seit kurzem laufen jetzt erste
tests 2400 meter straße wurden hier
unter freiem himmel angelegt und zwar
aus unterschiedlichen materialien also
strecken mit verschiedenen texturen und
unterschiedlicher griffigkeit wie die
bast auf ihrer webseite schreibt dazu
kommen flächen zu wenden und parken
insgesamt ist das testgelände rund
25.000 quadratmeter groß seit juni 2015
wurde es gebaut die kosten lagen bei
rund 13 millionen euro dafür soll es
aber auch 30 jahre lang genutzt werden
es geht um wirklich spektakuläre ideen
intelligente brücken die mit sensoren
ausgestattet sind oder beispielsweise
straßen innerhalb kürzester zeit mit
hilfe von betonfertigteilen gebaut
werden können sowie ein ikea regal eine
idee die hier außerdem getestet wird
sind selbstheilende straßen das
wundermittel magnetische partikel die im
bau gemisch enthalten sind funktionieren
soll das ganze dann wie ein
induktionskochfeld das magnetische
töpfer hits der beteiligte ingenieur
sebastian backer zieht den vergleich auf
dem testgelände ist die straße der topf
und das induktions gerät das eingesetzt
wird die
der platte denn induktions energie
erwärmt die magnetischen teilchen
schlagartig wir tun das mit asphalt als
bindemittel eingesetzt wird dehnt sich
aus und auch seine zähigkeit verändert
sich die folge kleine risse schließen
sich damit kann dann kein wasser
eindringen das dann im winter gefriert
und die straße weiter zerstört dafür
benötigt wird dann nur eine induktions
maschine mit der man die straße abfährt
und sie dadurch sehr viel langlebiger
macht der fachbegriff dafür heißt hier
rot vorbei also die zeiten in denen die
straßen dicht sind weil alle 500 meter
eine neue baustelle den verkehr
blockiert zudem soll damit geld gespart
werden und auch eine weitere idee die
auf dem kölner testgelände getestet wird
könnte den verkehr revolutionieren
straßen die strom produzieren das fett
erhitzt sich ja im sommer stark schade
um die energie die doch eigentlich
genutzt werden könnte und genau das ist
der plan ein rohrnetz in der oberen
schicht der straße würde mit hilfe von
kühlflüssigkeit energie abführen die
könnte dann in einem zweiten schritt in
strom umgewandelt werden der absolut
geniale nebeneffekt bei diesem prozess
sinkt die temperatur der straßen
es entstehen deutlich weniger spuren
gerade auf autobahnen sind ja auch
ziemlich gefährlich und das würde
baustellen und staus enorm verringern
die so entstandenen straßen müssen im
winter und bei frost übrigens auch nicht
mehr mit salz gestreut werden denn durch
die rohre könnte dann warmes wasser
laufen dass die straßen so von unten
wärmt es könnte erdwärme dafür genutzt
werden so dass dafür auch nur wenig
energie verbraucht werden würde und das
kölner testgelände ist nicht das einzige
forschungsfeld zum verkehr und den
straßen der zukunft wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler aus münchen
tüfteln an der lebenden straße spezielle
bakterien sollen im straße material
angesiedelt werden die idee dahinter die
mikroben werden quasi durch das wasser
das durch entstehende schadstellen in
die fahrbahn laufen würde aktiviert ihre
ausscheidungs produkte könnten dann
dabei helfen den beton wieder zu
verkleben also abzudichten auch mit
diesem verfahren würden dann größere
straßenschäden durch gefrierendes wasser
in der zukunft schon im vorfeld
verhindert werden und an intelligenten
straßen wird hier gearbeitet die die
idee dahinter sensor warnsysteme dem
asphalt integriert sind würden schäden
oder glatt heißt direkt
entsprechende techniker und wartungs
teams weiter geben diese infos würden
auch selbst fahrende autos mit wichtigen
infos versorgen und sollen letztendlich
zu weniger staus und unfällen verhelfen
fest steht jedenfalls die straßen der
zukunft werden mehr sein als langweilige
graue asphaltpisten zumindest innen drin
oder unten drunter
wenn es mehr infos zu den
forschungsergebnissen vom dura bast und
allen anderen forschern und
forscherinnen in diesem bereich gibt
erfahrt ihr natürlich hier
wenn er kein video dazu verpassen und
dann wird mir hier ein aber aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
denn nur dann erfahrt ihr nur wirklich
dann wenn ein neues video online gehen
und hier geht es weiter mit tempo 200
unterirdisch durch die stadt einer
innovativen lösung von wem wohl
ihnen muss einfach draufklicken wenn es
euch interessiert und ansonsten bis dann